speech of a coward when he got rushed
said I'm here to fight you know and
saying attack me I'm if you come face to
face but they never come face to face
see I'm CH in front of you by you you
you scar that's what I'm saying spe just
said he just he just he just said he
just said his God came to no fight that
card of a coward a coward would say I'm
not here to fight all the time even
getting beat up in understand the people
that attack me they run away from us you
see is they cut the video he's God with
SC you see he go going to fight
yesterday with the Muslims and the
Muslims helped him they did Muslims
helped him the
Muslims he C his mom that's what the do
we don't speak to card we don't speak
now if we look at Muhammad's activity in
the first 12 years Prophet muhamad
better than him this guy muhamad better
than him this guy he C his mother he C
his mother we don't speak someone and C
his
mother
R fight and Allah gave him and he F you
go the H anyway muham mammad is the best
example for mankind how can you follow a
coward who had to run away because he
was scared and the only way he could
actually come back and establish Islam
in his own city was to come with an army
cowardice okay no problem I'm not done
yet he had no
ability you can move back champ
sh go on
your sh you
coward
wasn't believes my God a
ID that him should not stop the other
Muslim from be this idiot stupid foolish
idiot
I I will knock you
out you
see and the Muslim should not stop other
Muslims from beating up this guy this
guy is
idiot you way you
go my brother brother you want to speak
to
me yo you read Arabic
right only
onean says you
we you guys are running you guys are
running your body
youan ask me
youan please
anyway we speaking about because you
came on when I was speaking to
him you know the he got into a fight I'm
not sure if you were there were you
there calm down I want to ask you a
question before you ask me a question
let me speak you don't come and just
dictate here okay go okay cuz they you
jumped on in the middle of conversation
that I was dealing with so I have to
deal with it I'm not sure if you were
there you said you not there so show you
the Muslims are real man he got into
fight with some Muslims at the da table
and it's been recorded in the the
channel as da yeah other Muslims got
involved by stopping it aldah you see
the Muslims were not evil by coming all
together and Rush him some Muslims
stopped no they stopped they stopped
literally I saw other brothers you saw
it alhamdulillah okay okay you're sorry
here they are so he when I said to him H
yeah yeah him no it was not him it was
the other guy the black guy
anyway anyway the brother was there so
what happened when I told him I said
don't fight he tried to mock the way was
attacked I mean no one Mo the except the
coward cuz how I was attacked someone
came said Salam I have a question in the
middle of night I mean late night in the
park is dark three people came behind me
rush me they're not on way okay
away alhamdulillah so I was there so I
said to him if this the case I must be
more Brave than your God because your
God was crying when the Romans were
picking him up right do you agree with
that I mean it was a prophecy that Jesus
Christ want to our sins because we
believe in the trying God in the nature
of the trying God there is one will
Jesus has he lays down his life by his
own accord No Greater Love is this the
one who lays down the life for his feet
for the friends so in the Triune godhead
Jesus wants to die for our you just as a
purpose why he
Jesus want to die for because he was you
agree with me he was scared I'm brave
okay so in the Incarnation the hyp I'm
not tell hypostatic
Union listen carefully to my question
I'm not asking you about the essence of
God the nature of God you not dealing
with my point my point is you just what
you just did you justifying why your God
was scared and was crying when God is
all powerful and the Romans will beaten
him up so therefore therefore therefore
therefore therefore therefore therefore
the the coward you should not Bel and
rebuke
people can I expl shake my hand
okay sh anyway the the point here is
therefore you go you you should not
rebuke and Bel to someone who is a
coward because your God was a coward
according to you I don't believe that by
the way we we say God in his nature was
a
because we believe in the Incarnation
like it says in col 29 and Philippians
2:6 that God put on mag he became a bant
he took on the form like a youth to
represent us to show us how to live life
and because in the Incarnation he was
limited so he wasn't God so no so okay
let me explain so because he was limited
in Incarnation the human tissue he had
was like it was like it was like us the
human flesh Allah couldn't become Allah
can't become like a man because he's
limited a baby he be limited wait wait
before we talk about Allah remember you
got become limited so you got limited he
just God limited God
ination can I can I expl before explain
wait wait before explain he
to for saying that we believe God is
lied then he believe God be a man when
he be
man but you have to let me finish he
became limited and what it means that he
theh was wait wait wait wait wait wait
everything became limited why because
according to your Bible that Jesus was
according to your belief the bible say
that explicitly according to your
according to your belief according to
your belief Jesus was a man and a God
the same time correct so which part of
you is God okay let me explain now so we
believe in the Incarnation in colians 2
that was my
question I know that God became a born
servant why is because no Prophet no man
can be the perfect example for
human
explain mhammad ask about
Jesus
let time is going to tell me life story
and I'm not here I never left my wife
and my beautiful children wife for
you God in his nature was limited in the
human nature lied which part listen my
question my brothers and my sisters
everyone here listen to this my question
is simply clearly which Jesus according
to your belief was God and a man listen
carefully was a God and a man at same
time
correct question let me ask a question
which part of Jesus Is God so do you
know who the story do you know who the
story do you know what happened at the
Council of what happened at the council
askes so a guy called
try to divide Christ into two persons he
said that Christ consisted of a human
person and a god person but we do not
believe that we believe that Christ was
one person this one person consisted of
two Natures now St syon of Alexander
Church Father to the fact of question do
you know
J I'm listening the question I'm I'm
expl okay which part of this has water
okay can I explain to you can I explain
to
you let me brother what does kosis kosis
means the limitation the emptying into
the Divinity to CH ful into the human
tissue fully good and fully was fully
fully man so the man that was crying was
that God as well that was a human nature
that okay so his nature as God so he's
good wa so you had two nature correct
wait wait wait wait wait so you said he
had two nature defined what his nature
so we believe in the church called Kos
kosis attributes to his because he came
like us he was not going to be arrogant
and Bo that he was God he was not going
to boast of he came to be a humble
servant and because he was in his humble
State he was acting as a born servant so
when Christ was crying that was simply
him being a bond servant but we know
Christ in John 2:19 Jesus said destroy
this temple in three days I will raise
up that's Christ ask question that's
Christ being used he's a Chris like him
he
know preaching no no no no he can take
you no no
I'm before you ask him ask
him ask my brothers and sisters ladies
and
gentlemen next to
my okay so you know he can answer
that's can it or not can answer it me
let me let me my dear brothers and
sisters ladies and gentlemen as you can
hear and you can see he's struggling to
explain his belief in human being with a
sound intellect you ask him the question
I've asked him Define what is nature and
ask him to tell me about history
defition what is nature what we have
what is it you have fleshly nature God
is a divine nature and as I was saying
to you question
became he had divine nature God God
Supernatural divine nature we have a
human nature God has a divine nature
what is God's nature step by step okay
so okay so God is a supernatural Divine
being the Incarnation understand each
other God's nature for example he has
the perfect
knowledge
nature nature if this is the case you
just told me according to the Bible that
Jesus when he became human he put his
God's nature aside I didn't say that I
didn't say that the Bible get in the
Bible said get in the Bible can I get it
I got him in
Philippians
I I him again did not lose his rutes he
did not use them to his Advantage only
when it was willed with the godhead
that's why in John 2:9 Jesus destroy
this temple in days how can Jesus raise
the flesh if he wasn't God if Jesus was
not God how did he rais himself back up
Jesus because they work together
father wa wait wait wait yeah you said
Jesus rose himself back up J you caught
yourself out on that one we don't
believe that okay so who raised him the
father of Jesus
can listen don't tell me your last story
simple question simple question
according to the Bible who raised Jesus
is it the father or Jesus brilliant I
love this question so first of all he is
going by ter called modelism modelism is
where people divide
Christ
father We Believe father question that's
why Christianity
because simp answer
asking
answer Jesus answer destroy this temple
in three days I will raise
up Stu up I will raise up I'll give you
where the Bible says the father raised
him up I will get the
Bible has Spen what his
body okay Step St
listen listen listen I'm going to I'm
going to show you now we clearly
said are you scared to say
yes me scared scared scared
scared let me show you are you scared
let me speak are you scared I'm going to
show you where he says the father raised
him up okay so the father raised him
up you have to drug so the one the
father is than I yes when
Jesus okay wait wait wait on the day of
judgment wait wait he said excuse
me according to the R1
correct1 okay brother Jamal get
the Corinthians when on the day of
judgment everyone was sub to Jesus every
be
then Jesus will be subordinate to the
father that are not one you
byebye let me exp Let Let Me expain
Jesus whatever the father does the son
does
likewise the father Jesus do like wait
the
father Jesus Jesus can do greater than
Prophets
whatever wait wait wait whatever the son
does the father does can I explain
explain just said it explain asking you
youe
so I don't know the
because Jesus was in humanity when Jesus
said nobody knows y it's because Jesus
was in this Humanity that's why are you
like
him are you B than him are you than
him you like him I
Can't Believe In thearch traran You
Believe In Father the father a the son
is
regenerating
Spirit do you know what that mean
what
I that's why he get involved he knows
that you are losing he knows that you
are losing that's why
involved
jbody
knows to go I don't
understand go go list
a question before you explain you
explain many times to the Bible before
you
explain because you will story without
asking the question so my you said the
Father and Jesus are one correct in Ence
in essence yes so so when Jesus getting
beat up are the father getting beat up
okay so no because no one they were
distinct
Ence the second person of the
trity creat everything he know that you
Los so the second
person Incarnation they have different
roles
theyes they differentes
we have differentes the
father let me
exp so here you can
see Christians out there look how Islam
so simple and it goes in line with our
sound intellect our natural inclination
look Allah Des
say Allah it is one is self-sufficient
everything need of him he's in need of
nothing he nothing neither he begotten
We Believe Allah the creator of
everything based upon his mercy and his
wisdom and his Justice he chose amongst
us to convey the message not God become
a baby baby is not God God is human
being God is Not Human Being a baby who
scared God knows everything Jesus Is God
but is not everything is a lot of
confusion you know it's a lot of
confusion and you are confused too you
can see that clearly okay that's God
know
everything know
everything so he must know everything
Jesus said in the Bible I don't know the
hour come I so here have a Christian he
didn't know that in the Bible says Jesus
doesn't know the hour like
him you must be worse if you B than him
you must be worse he's worse that's it
anyway so my dear brothers out there
ladies and gentlemen you see how many
people love me brother you call me more
he calls me more than my wife
CH I wish my wife called me many times
like Himi
they can't call by your first name in
Islam they to say by your second name
don't they respect of respect they have
to say your second
name anyway I me I challenge you to why
you challenge me because I saw you
YouTube
you
anyway what's my name what's my
name you watch my content you know my
name know my denomination my brothers
and sisters ladies and gentlemen out
there the Christians are struggling to
tell you about the belie
listen he want to
discuss you
Lear I
youus are you pulling why you pulling
his I I don't speak to you you waste of
time like him about the abortion in your
Shia so I want to talk about abortion
and I want to don't push me I want to
talk about
abortion come here he will
[Music]
follow talk
about I want to talk about abortion
there are three things I want to talk
about
I and being made out
of be better with you your b l you got
cooked by me better with all of you
your
B I want to talk about abortion I want
to talk
about and are being made out of pick the
free I'll do whatever you want I'll
defend my Bible and you can defend your
Quran I to yeah so I will okay
beautiful you said it's a logical
contradiction for God to be man because
they are contradictory predicates did
you not I never said this word yes you
did I never said this you did not
say not saying you did not say anyway
anyway anyway well I said to him okay
cuz you going to speak You're Dy speak
to me correct and I know I'm going to
waste my time with you exactly because
you're not stbn guy like okay okay when
God is the Father and Jesus are the same
so they're same in substance distinctive
person as me like you like me and you
well no cuz we're particular
substantiations of the the universal
human Essence ask you haveh you have a
skin am I am I answering your no not
answer my question topical way answer
you answer my question again are you do
you have
skin I'm ask a simple question as a test
to see of time you
have you have a skin yes simple you have
a
skin know is
byee hey ask me ask me my name ask my
name ask me my name my name name in
Algeria and Morocco and Pakistan your
basic philosophy called way of man name
therefore name indicate go home and
sleep that's
it the video
you see how crazy is you asking him you
have skin particularly in my country we
went to China then we came back to show
you my brother was a waste of time
because brother if I say you have skin
you're going to say yes I have skin you
can answer it simply why do you know why
the Christian are doing this you don't
know why because they noticed they
cannot defend Christianity based upon
the Bible what they started doing start
bringing people with
philosophy start trying to confuse
people with big words I've noticed that
you ask him a simple question then he
tells you the the church father aru he
was
Inu I'm asking you is the father and the
son is say you know what they mean by
same substenance and different
personality or person like you and I we
have the same substenance skin flesh
everything but we're different person so
therefore we're not save we're not save
but to play around to answer the
question directly cuz they know if they
answer the question directly they will
be exposed and there many Christians
will know they canot ask their beliefs
what they do they start answering with a
philosophical way so don't ever say we
scared to debate the Christians because
waste of time any chrisan you ask him
outside speakers do you have a skin and
flesh he say yes I do have skin of Flesh
simple answer
but here they will go to China then to
Morocco they come to Britain and they
will never ask the
question alhamdulillah for Islam
alhamdulillah for Islam you know the way
they preach Jesus never spoke like this
Jesus never used the terminologies they
are
utilizing understand ald